Doug argued for a run to be part of a  contact group bringing together if you  like the principal sponsors to the  conflict given how difficult it is to  find a way for so what not at least  talks but sitting in a lot even more so  and i press the Foreign Secretary on  Monday in the house of commons on  exactly this issue I think it'll be a  matter of regret if Iran is not at these  talks because on any reckoning given its  heavy responsibility supporting Assad  providing troops providing weapons it's  a key actor on the Syrian stage and as  we've seen with the chemical weapons  deal once you get those previous  adversary's in this case Russia and  other countries together you actually  can make some progress so I think it  will be a matter of regret if Iran is  not there but it's still important to  try and make progress on yard